la requête en révision du procès de
Christian ranousi guillotiné il y a 5
ans pour le meurtre d'un enfant a
peut-être de nouvelles chances d'aboutir
une enquête est en effet actuellement
menée par un haut-fonctionnaire de la
police et pourrait faire ressortir des
faits nouveaux les précisions de Paul
Lefèvre Christian ranouci vous le savez
a été condamné exécuté le 28 juillet 76
pour avoir assassiné le 3 juin 74 une
petite fille de 8 ans qui s'appelait
Maria Dolores Rambla il avait toujours
protesté de son innocence au cours du
procès mais il faut se rappeler qu'il
avait avoué deux fois la première fois
devant les policiers du SRPJ de
Marseille et la seconde fois devant le
juge d'instruction euh qui avait conduit
l'information ce dossier est un dossier
très difficile pour ma part je considère
qu'il y a autant d'éléments de
culpabilité que de zonees de doute
l'instruction de l'affaire anucci vous
vous souvenez sans doute a été très
rapide et surtout mené sous la pression
de l'opinion publique le procès à ex
également étit difficile avec la foule
qui criait à mort dans la salle et
autour du palais de justice d'ex je me
souviens très bien j'y étais il y a dans
la procédure c'est vrai un certain
nombre d'irrégularités et aujourd'hui
une demande de révision est présentée
par les deux avocats de Ranucci maître
Jean-Denis Brodin et Jean-François le
forcené cette demande de révision est
appuyée sur deux éléments d'abord
concernant les aveu on s'est aperçu que
quelques lignes avaient été ajouté
au-dessus de la signature de ce Ranucci
sur le procèsverbal d'aveu et on ne sait
pas très bien qui a écrit ces quelques
lignes deuxième élément là il concerne
ça concerne un témoignage la veille du
meurtre Ranucci aurait eu une
altercation à Marseille avec quelqu'un
et ce quelqu'un a été retrouvé Ranucci
on avait toujours parlé de cette visite
à Marseille la veille du meurtre et il
avait dit qu'il était ivre et le
témoignage de de cette personne confirme
les policiers ont toujours repoussé
cette déclaration de Ranucci en
présendant qu'il se trouvait à Salerne à
C à cet moment-là et cette déclaration
étaayait d'une certaine manière la thèse
de l'innocence pour l'instant une
contreenquête est menée par le
commissaire divisionnaire le bruscheek
et ses résultats seront examinés et là
c'est une procédure nouvelle par une
commission composée des représentants de
la Chancellerie des avocats de Ranucci
et de l'avocat de la famille de la
petite fille maître pierroni de Toulon
la conclusion les conclusions de cette
commission serontensite proposé au Garde
des saau qui s'il le juge utile
transmettra le dossier à la Cour de
cassation en Pologne un mois après la
proclamation de l'état de